torturas y privaciones ilícitas de la
libertad prácticas como éstas habrían
sido utilizadas por el gobierno del
entonces presidente mexicano enrique
peña nieto- para sustentar la versión
oficial sobre la desaparición de 43
estudiantes en la localidad de
ayotzinapa así lo afirma la fiscalía a
pocos días de que se cumplan siete años
de lo ocurrido mucho de lo que se hizo
para poder quererla sustentar fue
obtenido de manera ilícita
eso quiere decir que incluso
testimoniales de personas fueron
obtenidas por tortura fueron privadas
ilegalmente de la libertad fueron
aisladas por completamente de la
protección de la ley la polémica versión
que el gobierno de peña nieto denomina
verdad histórica habla de que los
estudiantes fueron detenidos en
septiembre de 2014 por policías
corruptos en la localidad de iguala en
el estado de guerrero posteriormente
entregados al cártel en guerreros unidos
que luego los asesinó e incineró en el
basurero de cocula para luego tirar sus
restos al río san juan una hipótesis que
no es del todo clara a los familiares y
que quedó desvirtuada en julio del año
pasado por la comisión de la verdad con
la identificación que desarrolló en la
universidad de innsbruck nos ha
permitido identificar al estudiante
normalista de la escuela normal de
ayotzinapa
cristian alfonso rodríguez del hombre 12
desaparecidos en la noche del 27 de 2014
que el estudiante fuera encontrado a un
kilómetro de distancia del basurero en
el que supuestamente habían sido
incinerados no sólo puso en duda la
versión oficial sino que dio un giro al
caso que ahora persigue a los antiguos
investigadores